well the Daily wires ben shapiro just
wrapped up the speech hosted by the
College Republicans here's a sample
something has to be done about a system
where a few crazed leftists decide they
don't want to hear somebody speak and
therefore people from the outside who
pay taxes to universities like this one
can't get in it's a great thing that
universities have people like me and yes
like the person who's speaking opposite
me on this campus to give a variation of
ideas oh my gosh those words are so
dangerous I mean the university actually
offered I kid you not
counseling to students who might be
upset even at the mention or the thought
of Shapiro's appearance he looks like an
unsuspecting guy to me well let's ask
the man himself appearing on the angle
exclusively in a new segment we're
calling back to school it's kind of a
Ron D Rodney Dangerfield thing
did you traumatize snowflakes on campus
tonight man I mean you look so just
innocent and nice and they seemed very
upset about the prospect of your
arriving you were in the stores campus
correct yeah that's right I mean it is
so yeah it was very intimidating I mean
beneath this innocuous exterior lies the
heart of a monster and I just went in
and started tearing people apart I
jumped into the audience I know I ripped
at least one guys throw it out but in
actuality none of those things happened
of course and and this is what's so
funny I mean this is the last campus
where they've had to bring out dozens of
security members of the dozens of cops
the staties were on call apparently all
because of what happened when when
Lucien came to speak and that's not rare
I mean when I was at Berkeley they had
to bring hundreds of police officers
when I was at Northwestern they banned
the the public from from coming when I
was University of Wisconsin the front of
the stage was taken over I'm when I was
at Cal State LA and your riot broke out
so it varies based on campus tonight
thank God was was actually relatively
calm I think a lot of that had do with
the fact that the university really did
its job in getting a lot of security out
there part of me heads with the fact it
was cold these are Fairweather
protesters they're not going to show up
when it's 30 degrees that's but part of
it part of it too I think is that the
the number of people who are allowed in
was limited if you were from an outside
group you weren't allowed to come even
though there were all these security
officers available now was it packed out
banned it was a full full
tore hammer yeah I mean they couldn't
given us bigger space there about 500
seats all of them were full yeah but
they did prevent people who wanted to
come in from the outside coming in I was
told by the College Republicans there
another six to seven hundred people who
wanted to come in and who were turned
away because if you're just a taxpaying
member the public and you wanted to come
they wouldn't allow you without it like
Donald Trump I had it seven hundred
people outside and they couldn't get it
I'm just using there were ten thousand
people outside they would know been
there were so actually we have a clip we
have a clip of a student who actually
wanted to get in tonight let's watch it
basically said that even if there's open
seats and also unclaimed wristbands
they're still not gonna let us into the
actual event do they tell you why nope
they just said they said they're not
people to talk to that there's nobody
that will will come in and talk to us
and even if there is somebody inside
there that you know could help us or
could kind of sort this out they're not
gonna come out and talk to us what do
you make of that they don't want to scho
this one why because Ben's her peer oh
no I couldn't tell from that clip or by
the look of the guy whether he was like
a friend or a foe I was guessing foe but
then at the end I said friend I couldn't
really tell I was like this man I could
but apparently they were they're like
poor people want to come in like no you
can't go at some point like my two of my
brothers went to UConn so I know the
stores canvass there's a long time ago
but I know it quite well and it can't be
that scary for them just to hear a
conservative speak it pot it can't
you it you know I don't think that it is
as I said in the speech if you actually
have to go seek mental health counseling
because you hear that I'm coming to
campus you probably need to seek mental
health counseling for a number of other
issues that you have but again it's the
security that I think is the new way the
tensor ship is taking place so as I've
said you know they're a bunch of
campuses now where the administration
says yeah we're happy to have a
conservative speak but we're not going
to allow people to to come and actually
hear this that's what happened to
Berkeley they had a 1,500 seat theater
they ruled out the top half of the
theater and I prevented people who came
same day from actually attending it's
not restricted to me this is happening
to a bunch of conservative speakers
around the country all in the name of
safety but Anita
spoke at UConn last week and it was
completely open to the public so all you
need to have is a few leftists who are
who are nasty and make threats and then
presumably the entire public is barred
from coming in the name of safety of
course so it's like Obamacare you have
access to care in theory but you don't
really have carry your there but you
can't really hear you I just have to
read then because this is I was like
crying laughing the diversity officer at
UConn Joelle Murchison in her letter
that just you know went out before your
speech so we understand even the thought
of an individual coming to campus with
the views that mr. Shapiro expresses can
be concerning and even hurtful please
utilize the many campus resources
available if you should want to talk
through your feelings about this issue
including my office the cultural centers
Dean of Students I actually want to go
pay her a visit and say I've had it I've
had a tough day today and I just I
really need some you know just a hug I
mean you just need a hug well then I'm
glad you look like you has no more
useless it was fun and and I will say
this there's no more useless title on
campus than chief diversity officer
whose entire job is to just pretend to
care about a bunch of people who are too
weak need to actually come in here in
the setting point of view